the last 30 years bobo has been calling
in with what he says is content content
for the show
he has several legal pads full of
questions he's the you know what they
shouldn't call them legal anymore bobo's
using them oj's using them
i think most of the audience would agree
the questions aren't great and before we
went on break i challenged bobo i said
bubba why don't you work on your
questions over the summer and his
assignment was to come up with what we
call the ultimate question
okay we set him up with a series of
celebrity coaches to evaluate his
questions give him feedback so that he
would be on the right track the first
coaching session we set bobo up with was
not one but three comedy pros andy
richter one of the funniest guys i've
ever met fred armisen another funny
[ __ ] guy you know
and i baron holds who i'm a huge fan of
so three guys that i really respect
like ike too
and things got off to a rocky start as
they often do with bobo hey it's i i
just want to say i am totally awestruck
with all of you to be here today uh
calling into the show 30 years you know
i do write down a lot of my questions
because uh you know it's impossible to
remember everything
and one of my favorite ones that i
didn't get to ask him is for you know
for years he's been going to therapy and
he made no bones about that i
had wanted to ask him you know going to
therapy
you think that would have changed you
like
as a
normal type of guy and already in other
words it'll bring you down a few notches
you know what i mean
no
i don't i don't what do you what do you
mean bring you down if you're not what
is th what what is
is there
what is the question
andy fred and ike had some good thoughts
once they clarified what the question
was
well the question is you know like were
you ever concerned that going to therapy
over the years could you know
changed you into a well-adjusted guy in
the radio because i don't make you less
funny yeah yeah because like when he had
chris rock on chris rock was saying that
he goes gee i was concerned about it it
was going to change me from being a
funny guy
so then i just took that and changed it
around and you know want to turn into a
question to howard about himself i feel
like that is a question that we know the
answer to
because he's still in therapy right
you know so the answer would be like no
i don't you know and also too i would
say that's a yes no question yes so
you're saying scrap the question um
maybe there's some other angle about
therapy
that would you know like that maybe make
an essay question about like you know
what have you learned in therapy that
has helped you on the show the most okay
something like that okay
because that's that's an answer that he
has to sort of you know stretch right
here's where it gets good instead of
moving on to his second question bobo
decided to do some ass kissing so he
started with fred armisen these guys
just wanted to
get on with it and help him what i
wanted to you know say too about each
one of you like fred man i just love you
on snl for years thanks your favorite
bit that you know i like was when you
did prince that was amazing spot on
thanks i i'm a big fan of prince so that
that's all it was it was just you know
and this is also to your sketch comedy
portlandia and uh season one episode two
when you were in the bike lanes and oh
yeah yeah because i'm more about safety
with vehicles and and bikes and you know
i appreciate it thank you just because i
i do i do i do want to see my children
grow is there a another is there another
question so i got all upset because he
was just trying you know he was trying
to be a nice guy and help bubbo out and
was turning into a really long call yeah
well he's trying to help us out he
wouldn't have gotten on the phone for
bobo and now he's got this drone
just wasting his time
he didn't realize what was going to
happen when he said yes to this bobo bit
you know he really didn't understand
that it could be all day yes
so then
in true bobo fashion he tried to
compliment ike baron holtz but clearly
he was confusing him with eric andre oh
no yeah yeah it really was horrible and
andre you you really tortured me on the
phone lines dude you you mean ike
yeah i mean
bubba honestly you can call me andre
brother
i wonder who he thought you were andre
3000 probably
maybe no like you really you really did
but i i got to say ike too that i love
your pranks when you come out of the
water with the cement shoes i love that
one also on the subway train how do you
pull off that stuff with the pranks
bobo do you think i'm on the show on
practical jokers
i thought you do what train you know i
thought you do um the pranks oh maybe
i'm i got that mixed up the cement shoes
do you mean like punt like punk yeah do
you think i'm ashton kutcher yeah faked
yeah i thought you did you thought i was
ashton kutcher
no not ashton cushit but i thought you
thought i was on the show punk no i
thought it was a show that you had that
um oh maybe he thinks you're eric andre
eric andre's
oh cause he said andre yeah yeah yeah
maybe i mix you up first of all even if
it was eric andre he's calling him andre
i mean i know he's calling her by his
last name
bobo papa what what happened to you you
you choked
well what happened was it was this the
twi envelope of andy and fled and ike
when i see some weberties like that i
get dumb stricken struck dumb
dumbfounded choked up word wish
tongue-tied inarticulate voiceless
unvoiced unspoken dumb mute unspeaking
voice was soundless and blameless
anyway bobo's session with andy fred
and ike ended up with some useful advice
this is my uh question that i i think
will get some
interest going with him
uh because we all know how he loves
painting okay and how he always you know
talks about you know like he'll go to
remote locations take photographs and
then come back to his home studio and
paint them
so i just want to ask him have you ever
tried maybe over vacation going outside
of your home studio perhaps at a remote
location and setting up an easel and
painting outdoors
now the colors and everything are more
vibrant it pops right and here i'll do
i'll do howard no no there you go i mean
i again i think there's a way to get out
art questions but kind of be like who
what artists are you inspired by like
okay is is there a location that you'll
probably never travel to that you wish
you could just so you could paint it
right okay yeah all right well thanks
and you could give him some you know
examples yeah yeah but avoid the yes no
like you know take the topic and think
of a way that where it's more of a
conversation
starter than just a yes no gotcha but
other than that it was all right it was
good all right well thank you i wish i'd
been here 30 years ago just to give you
that note to avoid yes
yeah i could use that tutelage
well anyway it it was really funny and
uh bobo wait that what that wasn't my
question though what i wanted to say was
did you ever think that howard would get
in his car drive halfway to where he
wants to take his pictures then take out
his camera weave it on the ground then
drive back to the home studio and get
his easel then drive back to the camera
pick up the camera and drive to where he
wants to paint but weaves the camera in
the car
so he can paint more vibrantly your
thoughts
my impression of that conversation was i
could hear
the advice going in one of bobo's ears
and then out the other you know there's
nothing to trap it you know like it's
not going to be caught by anything and
staying
whatever that is he has in the top of
his head there he's just going right out
the
other ear bobo's next mentor was film
and television star michael rappaport oh
he and he was very blunt with bobo he
didn't mince words when it came to
helping bobo with his first question
here you go i mean mike uh might cut
right to it oh man look at [ __ ] boba
your beard looks awesome looks totally
natural looks [ __ ] great thank you
thank you you know i uh i enhanced the
ink a little bit on it did you like i
would never be able to tell it's just a
different look there mike you know
questions bobo let me get to the
question spit them out
jesus christ i don't think bobo would
ever um uh understand sarcasm when he
hears that yeah honestly no
g bobo you look great yeah no one would
notice
anyway so here bubble spews out the
question what i've crafted up uh the
first one
what would you say
is the reason why the new beavis and
butthead movie do the universe chose not
to release in the theater i i would say
strike that question bobo strike it
that's a [ __ ] that's just take it uh uh
and wipe your ass with that question
okay that that's a bad question the fact
that you've had all
summer
right to come up with the questions
that's what you want to ask howard stern
well i figured it biebers and butthead
he likes them and it's just something
that i i would wanted to know why they
wouldn't release in the theaters like
it's more wider audience
that's the question you want to ask did
she come out of your [ __ ] brain
anyway that did it didn't go well with
rapaport so then we tried jeff probst
you know who from survivor the guys had
43 seasons of survivor and uh oh god
bubbler started the uh coaching session
by plugging the new season of jeff show
which i'm not sure what that was about
hey now jeff probst what an honor to see
you i can't believe 22 years hosting
survivor and now 43rd season kicking off
in september 21st on cbs so i'm so
anxious to see this bobo thanks for the
nice promo oh absolutely great setup man
yeah thanks man no i love the show to
you this is about yes yes uh jeff really
uh tried to help bobo out i will say he
came up with a new question and they
gave bobo a pep talk he was very
positive with mobile here's another way
to think about
i'm not saying this is the question okay
if you were to ask howard
it's it's love or success
you can only have one at this point in
your life you've had this incredible
career all of this wealth
you're known everywhere your ego's
fulfilled all the [ __ ] time but you
also have this amazing wife that you
clearly love who happens to be
incredibly attractive still and you get
all that comes with that
but you can only have one if you were to
ask a question like that no matter which
way howard goes
there's a conversation this is the
biggest moment of your
career i know i know
imagine imagine this
you come up with the question
and you ask it and when the whole
conversation is over howard says god
admit didn't see that coming bobo well
done thanks so much jeff lots luck and i
look forward to seeing you on uh season
43 september 21st all right bobo i wish
you luck i'll be listening
now here's the kicker i love how what it
sounds like is bobo's not listening to
anything
no you're so smart because during the
process when uh john blitt was talking
to bobo after the whole thing
bubble told john blitz that he wrote
what he thought would be the ultimate
question
but decided not to share it with the
coaches
bobo said the question was perfect and
it didn't need any help so it was a it
was a total waste of everyone's time but
here we go it's time for bobo's ultimate
question this is my ultimate question
ultimate question
[Music]
ultimate question
ultimate question
ultimate
question
all right on my phone now is bobo
30-year fan
after you spoke to the coaches
what did you do in other words where did
you go to write
how did you write differently based on
your coaching what was the process to
come up with the bobo ultimate question
well i you know i first i was listening
to jeff popes you know all those guys
are great but when he that was an
important one he said and i
thought about that about your success
and radio and then you know best and
then i turned it into a question like if
you were given the choice of being in
love or your success that you have in
radio what would you choose you know
uh like a nine to five job or your
beautiful bet you know so uh yeah i did
pick out things that i thought were
important and they were all you know
orchestrated you know perfectly what did
you just say i have no idea
right okay jeff's pro jeff pope's
brilliant question i got to say this
yeah all right turned it into a stupid
question robin it is time now nine
i hope no one at home is operating heavy
machinery sit down because it's time for
the bobo ultimate questions
get ready to be amazed
america
is holding its breath here we go bobo
i'm going to turn the mic over to you
and allow you to ask the ultimate
question
all right what would you say
help you in your life to become such a
great communicator you know for having
the engaging interviews that you have
howard over the years because when you
started out you were very critical of
yourself
so you now you have elevated into a
master so what would you say
how you became such a great community
what what what got you to that point
well
all right if that's the ultimate
question bobo i will answer it uh
what now now but you know i don't want
to criticize the ultimate question
bubba's taking enough [ __ ] but
it's it's an obvious answer it's bobo
what made me
a great communicator if you will is the
amount of hours i put in number one
right i spent a lot of hours on the
radio i wasn't always good on the radio
i told you i was bad
and also
the freedom that i i gained when i
became more comfortable on the air it
enabled me to be funnier and to
communicate in a better way how's that
good and also your therapy right because
you
now don't answer the
that's a question
and now i will say there are a lot of
factors in my life
that helped me to become a communicator
for example i was talking about my
father yesterday i used to listen to my
father communicate with his friends
and i found him to be quick-witted and
funny with them
and he had a certain delivery and a
cadence that i liked
and it influenced me a lot
and i read a lot of mad magazines and i
watched a lot of funny television and
everything is an influence and that's
what shapes you
did you learn anything now that you
asked the ultimate question
how do you feel i answered the question
and robin's right what did you learn
from my answer no that you you know you
really put thought into it how you i
said it you broke it down you know
rather than just a yes or no question
you know i try to get something that's
engaging right you know what i mean they
did it you asked the ultimate question i
think all of america right now is kind
of shocked at what crafting you put into
this and uh i don't think anybody else
will ever call in with a question that
question was so good well how would you
rate this question
bobo how can anyone rate this it's it's
the ultimate question it's a on a scale
of one to ten it's a 15. i mean i'm
um
i have a i have a question though all
right if here's my one puppet
if i went to therapy don't you think
that i would never be an idiot again and
say more dumb moronic thoughts or
ridiculous questions your thoughts
therapy cure what's wrong with stupidity
it would have to be a highly trained
therapist it would have to be sigmund
freud himself
[Laughter]
and there you have it bobo's ultimate
question
ultimate question
ultimate question
bobo's ultimate question what was the
ultimate question
the question what made you become a
great communicator there it is you see
how it stays with you
ultimate question
[Music]
ultimate question
ultimate question